actually came up with this gears analogy
and first gear is about noticing our
habit Loops right if we can't move
notice them we can't move at all we're
always moving backwards second gear is
exploring what the result is like what
do I get from this and that's a really
critical step that people try to bypass
as much as they can CU intellectually
they know you know smoking or overeating
you know I know it's not good for me and
they they want to jump right to third
right to the end yeah yeah so third gear
is when we're actually stepping out of
the loop so we're being kind we're being
curious we're using these mindfulness
practices to actually step out of these
old habitual behaviors so what I see
most is people trying to jam it from
thirst and first into third gear and of
course you know they right like it
doesn't work you you're on a hill and
we're going to fall over on the bike
we're going to stall the car yeah yeah
yeah so you have to just embrace the
process as it's laid out yeah in front
of you